en direct donc de Matignon depuis 1936
la gauche a toujours voulu être à
l'origine des avancées sociales et la
réduction du temps de travail a toujours
été au cœur des programmes électoraux
des formations de gauche les grandes
étapes de cette évolution avec Roseline
Fèvre nous voulons rendre confiance en
elle-même à la France laadorieux c'était
l'engagement de Léon Bloom juste avant
la victoire du Front populaire avril
1936 gagne les élections puis suivent
mai juin de mois qui vont changer toute
notre histoire sociale la classe
ouvrière y croit et dans un grand
mouvement d'enthousiasme elle provoque
grève et occupation d'usine dans toute
la France pour forcer le Front Populaire
à honorer ses promesses et faire avancer
les négociations dans le Nord la plart
des usines sont occupé par les ouvers au
mois de juin le gouvernement Bloom
organise les négociations suivront les
accords de Matignon qui scelleront la
loi sur les congés payés et celle sur la
semaine de 40 he payé 48 en 1981 pendant
sa campagne électorale François miteran
veut suivre les pas de Léon Bloom et
ressortir les vieilles recettes de 36
dans les 110 propositions du candidat
mitéran il y a le passage au 35 he c'est
parce que je veux que chaque travailleur
travaille 35 he pour partager le travail
sans perte de salaire afin que les
entreprises emportées par la production
et la productivité c'est-à-dire gagnant
de l'argent embauche d'autres d'ailleurs
pour que les machines tournent après la
victoire de 81 on s'interroge sur la
réduction du temps de travail mais les
syndicats trépignent alors François
mitteran imposera les 39h payer 40 une
négociation qui sonnera le glas des 35
he 1997 Lionel Jospin entrera-t-il dans
l'histoire des avancées sociales le
slogan des 35 he fut la promesse
cardinale des socialistes autour d'une
formule réduction progressive du temps
de travail sans perte de salaire mais à
certain de traduire 35 he payer 39 même
après le discours de générale réduire le
temps de travail sans perte de salaire
représente à la fois un progrès
économique susceptible de créer de
nombreux emplois et un progrès social
pourtant l'ambiguïé va continuer Lionel
Jospin apporte donc une précision dans
le monde il explique que 35 he payer 39
c'est anti économique en fait de tout
temps et de tout gouvernement on a pensé
que la réduction du temps de travail
créerait des emplois ce fut l'espoir et
la déception économique en 36
aujourd'hui on tente encore une fois de
repenser cette solution sous toutes ses
formes et sous toutes ses coutures
Maurice Papon